-Well, you guys,
it is an exciting time.
In the world of marine biology,
recently scientists
have discovered four --
four -- new ocean species.
A new species of comb jelly,
a new species of sea snail,
a new tree spider crab,
and Earth's newest siphonophone.
To get the word out,
a fun group of performers
has been going around
to elementary schools
to teach children,
and we are so lucky --
so lucky
to have them here tonight.
So please welcome
The Four New Animals.
-Hey, hey, hey!
-Whoo!
-Yeah!
-Whoo! All right!
Are you ready to learn?!
-Yeah!
-Whoo!
Well, all right.
Let's do it. Here we go.
-[Rapping] ♪ There are four
new animals, come and see ♪
♪ Your new fun friends
that live under the sea ♪
♪ I'm Duobrachium sparksae,
a new kind of comb jelly ♪
♪ Like a clear plastic bag,
you can see through my belly ♪
♪ The way I move around
is like a hot-air balloon ♪
♪ Become a deep-sea diver
and visit me soon ♪
-This is so nice,
and it's probably a great way,
you know, for kids to learn.
♪♪
-♪ I'm Apolemia,
and to scientists ♪
♪ I'm a brand-new thing ♪
♪ I look like a pile
of silly string ♪
♪ They say
I'm the longest animal ♪
♪ And I think they are right ♪
♪ At least that's what
your girlfriend said ♪
♪ To me last night ♪
-Uh-ha-ha!
-I-I don't think that's okay.
-♪ I'm a bad new species
named Leptarma biju ♪
♪ And I'll sell you
crystal meth ♪
♪ The next time I see you ♪
♪ Light that pipe and ♪
-♪ Boom! ♪
-♪ You'll be high as can be ♪
♪ And for the rest of your life,
you'll be buyin' from me ♪
-This is definitely
not for kids.
♪ I stay slanging 'cane,
I stay snortin' coke ♪
♪ I stay at yo' mama's
'cause yo' daddy is a joke ♪
-This is not appropriate at all.
Maybe, but only maybe,
it's time to stop.
-♪ If you ain't got no money,
you can't hit it ♪
♪ If you ballin',
then I'm wit' it ♪
♪ Hit it from the front,
hit it from the back ♪
♪ Let a little bit
slide down my crack ♪
♪ I'm-a come over
to your place ♪
♪ I don't need a couch,
I'm-a sit on your [bleep] ♪
♪ Got a big [bleep]?
That's what I'm hopin' ♪
♪ Looking for a [bleep]
that'll crack me open ♪
Sea snail, bitch!
[ Laughter ]
-I would like to apologize
on behalf of NBC
for what a bad rapper
the green guy was.
We'll be right back
with Graham Norton.
-Unh-unh, unh-unh, unh-unh.
Unh-unh, unh-unh,
unh-unh, unh-unh.